il rénove embellissent comme julien ces
vacanciers et autres amateurs de petits
boulots sont en action dans les
différentes allées du cimetière de saint
pierre bien souvent en amont comme de
véritables professionnels ou négocié
avec le client ce niveau de la demande
et de la peinture s'il ya de la peinture
a fait aussi au delà du fait que évident
que la somme augmente ou sans nous
demander de l'aide en libye face une
bosse à plusieurs gros une belle
opportunité ou se faire un petit pécule
à cette période de l'année où les
martiniquais porte une attention
particulière à leur défunt depuis 12 ans
marc se polyvalent de la restauration
s'organisent afin de répondre à la
demande
je fais des urbains aussi matière à la
toussaint je pose mes jours de congés
conventionnelle restaurant japonaise de
congés toujours à la toussaint tout vous
des vacances où j'ai pu se faire un peu
plus d'argent entre eux pas de rivalité
ils sont tous du nord caraïbes
mais les plus jeunes manquent encore
d'expérience non plus entre les piles et
peut-il à eto'o ils veulent toujours
courir avant la volonté tôt mais bon en
fait j'ai déjà ma clientèle
c'est une bonne chose parce que ça ça
leur permet de se faire un peu d'argent
de poche
ça leur permet de financer certaines
dépenses et moi je me dis que tant que
les jeunes peuvent cobayes
ils sont sur la bonne voie la
transmission étape aussi très important
dans cette tradition elle se transmet de
génération en génération
la tradition martinique ça a toujours
été ainsi
les gens venaient avec la famille se
tiennent la famille à qui avaient des
enfants on emmenait les enfants pouvoir
faire le travail au cimetière pour les
toits et la tombe et ceux qui n'ont pas
d'enfant et qui ne peuvent pas qu'il
soit déjà j'ai payé quelqu'un pour
pouvoir le faire grâce à
l'investissement des familles et de tous
les tubes heures de l'île de mai
mercredi où l'on célébrera les seins et
jeudi les défunts les différents
cimetières de l'île aux hérons de mille
feux